[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah I'm very excited to now present to
you my latest product on chasuble and
it's called fight 1 e-form like Khurana
it was announced a bit ago on my channel
that this is in the works and now it is
completed ready and you can buy it on
chasuble calm so what is it all about
it's a full black repertoire and we came
to look at the chapters now it's a full
black repertoire to fight 1.e4 based on
the double King pawn e4 e5 and it covers
everything that might happen that means
we will have the first chapter for
example here on all the the gambit of
their relations that can happen the
King's gambit yeah we can have a look at
some Kings gambit craziness right here
when I click them so we have some
weapons against all the gambits we have
lines against early deviations like the
beginner game the bishops opening all
those lines that can be played on with -
we also of course have to feature
something against 293 and that will be
the petrov it's called 5 before like
karana karana has really made a
formidable weapon out of the petrov we
will cover the petrov proper everything
that might happen 3d 490 XE 5 the modern
main line with 593 so everything in the
petrov is covered but also it wide
declines basically the petrov and he can
do so by going 393 we forget the four
knights opening so it also has that
included the four knights
spanish the phone add scotch all those
lines that you would even be yeah very
happy to get some coverage of if you
don't play the petrol
don't tend to do that however I think
the patter of coverage is excellent and
really happy with the lines many lines
are extremely exciting and very very
tactical so it's really am an
interesting way to fight with black what
I definitely need to show to you if you
are new to chasuble is how this actually
works because it's not a classic let's
say a book or anything it's rather what
it is called like the move trainer it
really helps you to learn the lines move
by mouth so how does that work let's say
I go into a chapter and I want to learn
a certain line I could select the line
from a list of lines but I can also say
okay show me something that I have not
yet learned and that would be I mean I
learned one or two lines before I
started the video so I'm going here and
it now will show me what you do in this
particular position so I'm clicking next
and says okay you move take only form
well okay and there's a text that you
can read to yeah better understand what
this move should be played yeah and then
I basically have to place them on the
board and now okay I have to go back
okay so let's do that so I can learn
move by move basically the opening it
always has the information why a certain
move should be played and what the ideas
are behind the moves the great thing is
that the software recognizes the spots
where you make mistakes and those will
be presented to you again and again
so all those holds that you might have
in repertoire will be patched
automatically this is the great thing
about such a sophisticated software so
if we go back down and check out the
video again I actually made a Mis click
there so how does the video
yeah combined with the Move trainer this
is great now if you are in the video
yeah like here I have a screenshot in
the middle of a video I'm jumping to a
different spot Here I am
we're in the repertoire I can filter
based on the video position so if I'm in
the video and I want to learn more about
this particular line that is shown in
the video I can click on filter and it
will filter out all the lines so I can
get more information there on the text
on the text base if I want like I see
that the video picture and listen to the
explanation then I think I need to
really reread that so you just jump into
this part you can read the text and then
you can work from there like copy the
position turn to put it into analysis
engine things like that you can all do
that also in the video page there's
another feature then it's excellent when
you are actually in a certain line and
you have the opposite idea like okay
let's say here I want to watch the video
on that particular position so you can
jump to the video position and then you
can watch me explain the ideas behind
that line so that it works in two ways I
think it's an excellent way to learn
openings I always use my own opening
products that say to repeat my own
openings I prepare with the Move trainer
to record the videos and it works
excellently well so this is a product
that has the the basic move trainer
function with all the texts and the
ability to have this spaced repetition
for the moves and it has the videos and
I need to tell you how it is actually
priced if we go to the starting page
again I have a better overview there so
we have the basic move trainer variation
since all that moves all the variations
all the text this is 674 variations give
or take one or two a might find one they
need to add or delete so 670 roughly
variations and it has more than 50,000
words which is huge it's really it's a
huge chunk of text and
the nation you also get included with
the basic version close to four hours of
video the first chapter with all the
gambits will be included plus a preview
of all the other chapters of like
roughly 10 minutes so I have a good
impression how the other videos look
like and this is priced at $30 29:20
$29.99 I always have issues with those
numbers in English so let me run it up
in 30 and 30 dollars but we will have a
sale for I think it is 10 days and at
that time it will only be priced at 50%
of that so it will be 14.99 $15
basically which is a real steal if you
ask me then you have the option to get
the full videos which means it is not
going to be the close to four hours but
in additional 14 hours roughly of videos
so we will have almost like two-hour
video per chapter and you can also get
that of course and buy the video add-on
which is at normal times non-sale time
priced at 102 39.99 dollars 140 dollars
and this is reduced more than 50% even
during the sale - it's 64 point 99 $65
so if you purchase the whole thing
during sale its below 80 US dollars yeah
I think it's it's really it's great
value and all those and the videos
really make it a terrific product and
pretty much it's very much appreciated
if you get the full package because that
really makes the whole product yeah
worth producing with that effort that I
put into so I hope you like the preview
and that you are interested in the
product I think it's it's a great way to
build an opening repertoire based on the
double King pawn with black um based on
kiwanis choices yeah I've really really
tried to model it after what come on a
place in most cases it works very well
and some
the lines are obscure and not played on
the work class level in this case I have
selected good lines I think that are
interesting and exciting to play against
those rarer continuation so I think it's
a it's a great way to expand and improve
your opening repertoire make sure to
check it out on chasuble comm thanks for
watching
[Music]
you